It's amazing how much of our modern
political morality is influenced by the
philosopher John Stuart Mill and the
mill wasn't the first person to champion
individual freedom of choice,
but the case he makes in on liberty,
his most famous work is like a diamond
of thought put most succinctly.
He says that over himself,
over his own body and mind.
The individual is sovereign and if you
want to understand the complex issue of
who has the right to die,
you have to start here because it's this
principle of personal autonomy except in
cases where opposes harm to others.
That forms it's moral and legal basis.
In American courts,
at least the possession of that autonomy
has become synonymous with the word
dignity and words.
Terms in this debate have a lot of
importance.
They framed the way we think of the
question of doctor assisted suicide in
the beginning.
It was called euthanasia.
In 1938,
Dr Charles Francis Potter,
a unitarian priest and humanists founded
the euthanasia society of America,
the first group to seriously proposed
legislation that would legalize mercy
death.
At least that's what the New York Times
called the euthanasia society,
didn't like the terms death and killing,
and they preferred merciful release of
course for much of the public,
the term euthanasia was already a bit
too close to Eugenics,
something that the Nazis were going to
make disgustingly clear in the next few
years and the society wasn't doing much
distinguishing itself and the words of
its president,
euthanasia was for born defectives who
were doomed to remain defective.
If that terrifies you,
it should.
So for those who saw a genuine moral
imperative to help terminal sufferers
and their life on their terms,
it was an uphill battle.
And that battle too was waged in words.
In 1976,
the euthanasia society of America
changed their name to the Society for
the right to die.
In 1992,
they changed it again to choice in died
in 1993,
another group form called compassion in
dying.
And in 2002,
the former hemlock society changed its
name to end of life choices.
Finally,
merging with compassion and dying in
2003 to form compassion and choices.
You can see during a process of decades,
a careful reframing of the debate as one
about choice and personal autonomy.
I cosmo Kramer having just seen the
movie the other side of darkness and not
wanting to be in a coma like that lady
in the movie hereby want Jerry Seinfeld
to remove my life support,
feeding machine,
lung blower,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
First
victories came in the form of advanced
care directives or living wills and the
court decisions were loaded with the
language of autonomy and dignity to
justify pulling the plug in the case of
brain death.
And then when the first physician
assisted death,
laws were passed,
dignity was front and center again.
Indeed such laws are often called death
with dignity laws.
Today,
five states effectively allow physician
assisted death and in each,
the medication can only be prescribed
when certain requirements are met.
In Oregon,
for example,
you have to,
among other things,
be terminally ill with a fatal diagnosis
of less than six months.
The day that I learned that I was
terminally ill,
that there was nothing that medicine
could do to ameliorate even my symptoms.
Uh,
I decided that I wanted to live as long
as I could,
as best I was able and I want her to die
with dignity with which I had lived.
It's an extraordinary issue.
Physician assisted death.
It's legal victories have been carved
carefully from a complex and dangerous
moral backdrop in a country where
depression rates are as high as this
one.
It's not without risk to sanction any
form of suicide.
Death with dignity laws limit themselves
to terminally ill patients exclusively
because it's the only instance in which
we can recognize irrational desire to
end one's own life and all other cases.
Suicide is a permanent solution to a
temporary problem.
Of course,
opponents of physician assisted death
don't see a moral right in any instance
of suicide.
A lot of those opponents fall on the
conservative or religious side of the
spectrum where there's also a split
among progressives,
particularly on the part of disability
rights activists.
When those seeking aid and dying lists
the reasons for their choice reasons,
such as the inability to live without
help being a burden on their loved ones,
things often refer to as indignities
activist.
Point out that those with disability
live with such conditions for their
entire life.
They say that physician assisted death
laws can paint these kinds of lives as
undignified and that creates a larger
culture that the values the disabled.
This is what happens when an abstract
concept like dignity,
a concept that has no fixed meaning in
bioethics is invested with so much
weight.
80 one percent of people who seek lethal
medication do so because they worry
about a quote,
loss of dignity,
and yet whether dignity is a property
that can be lost.
It's still a matter of philosophical
debate.
I should say now that physician assisted
death is something that I support but
not without a little hesitation,
hesitation that's demanded.
I think by the blurred boundaries of a
moral question like this one.
The objections posed by conservatives,
disability rights activists and others
must be taken into account.
They don't negate.
It's neat,
but they do warn us that discussion
across the table isn't for going to
draft laws.
As subtle as the issue is,
mine is the morality of John Stuart Mill
in 2015 at only the latest moment in our
effort to understand the intricacies of
individual liberty and at the heart of
liberty is the right to define one's own
concept of existence,
of meaning,
of the universe,
and of the mystery of human life and
death.
Hey everybody.
Thanks for watching.
It was so enlightening researching and
learning about this issue.
It was just so many sides to it that I
wasn't aware of before before diving
into this.
Um,
so thank you for watching and thank you
to Eli Samuel for turning me onto this
and inspiring me to do this.
If you want to see more videos where I
explore topics like this,
you can pledge to my patrion page by
clicking right here.
Everything helps.
Um,
it is what makes this channel possible.
I said it over and over again,
but it's really,
really is true and you guys have been
amazing and the quality of the content I
hope you see has gotten better as I've
been able to do this full time.
So thank you so much for that and I will
see you guys next Wednesday.